what gonzalo hey it's been too long man
hello hi I sell melons would you like to
buy guess not
[Music]
I have to restart the entire game for
that all right lemon salah wants to talk
come on man let me enjoy whatever - yeah
yeah yeah yeah where's the wine oh no
here we are
that shrieky boys gonzalo all right guys
this has been great by the way
you look fabulous
[Music]
oh why did you say so girl hey I know
I'm fabulous I can't hear you over how
fab I am anyway I can't I like your ball
I like your ball like your balls to race
they're like how did [ __ ] how did he
know I'm gonna go to the kitchen
Gonzalo are you trying to leave the room
again
no well just come back to the living
room quit screwing around you guys are
mean okay no really don't come and get
some oh come on
we really just want you to come back in
here [ __ ] you you know what
no Gonzalo that's it ah you need to be
went through the wall yourself of ours
we invited you over but this is just no
lemme goat you demon you demon hunter
[ __ ] you [ __ ] off pieces piece of [ __ ]
god damn it I knew I should just take
the wine and left gods alo are you guys
fighting
all right then Gonzalo did you know I
thought I heard someone out here I'm
gonna take this wine this time and I'm
gonna leave it how do I exit I'm so
tired of them and their [ __ ] oh no
no no no no no did I close the door
thank you fins allo hi how are you got
it's been a while
you got good tips all right nope
gonzo no that's it No you've got no I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know come on no gotta go no [ __ ]
you
we can put up with a lot but we have our
limits you know you invited me fine just
go I compliment you [ __ ] everyone now
Gonzalo
in one word what does this picture say
to you yes good question good question
quack no wait what's wrong with that
that's a perfectly fine thank you no
just take your grace this romance oh god
it says oh god how do you do that man's
ha in our marriage that's just a car you
okay right now Trevor you're scaring me
Bella
that's not the first time he's done that
and you knew I play what happened the
game crashed no I was doing so well damn
it
Gonzalo it's so great to see you
it's been a while how's it going yeah hi
Wow so great to see you after so long
it's so happy Gonzalo
oh no no no Danny we have a guest we can
let the answering machine I'll get it
I'll get it I'll get it
probably just the cleaning service oh
who is this who is this grace is that
you oh it's my dad I can hear his voice
all right oh girl I'm grace dad okay
your daughter is a little [ __ ] to hit
her so much how old is this phone Jesus
Christ I
have you guys ever tried LSD no no
you've you've done quite enough with my
paranoia
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I wonder
how about your ass trip oh man
you weirded me out for a second there
they'll never find me here so long since
we've seen you how are you doing I'm
pretty good thank you
Ginevra damn it I missed me hi how are
you I am so happy to see you after so
long that's funny I said the same thing
hilarious so come in make yourself at
home
alright alright alright oh that that's
just a little joke advice-giver toy
thing that i like to consult every now
and then
alright well when i need a little
guidance his mother gave that to me he's
trying to play a cold you don't think I
got hard evidence here saying that
you're it whatever I was going oh Jesus
Christ she's close oh my god no one is
complaining about your dick I think I
mean sides sorry but this room is just
not working I'm going to return what
furniture do it I think I'm inside you
grace Ginevra wait grace no it's true
everything's fine what the [ __ ] is going
on Oh God Ginevra yes it's so funny how
you like to flirt with me cuz you have
nice tits give me some a great ass
don't kick me out don't kick me out
don't kick me out oh this is getting to
be too much right now
don't kick me out you know what I'll be
right back grace what do you know I'm
going to leave you two alone to keep
talking about marital issues and what it
going I'll just be in the kitchen it's
all right I'll go this is our moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
grace what Oh
I love you Ginevra I run away with me
Ginevra I can't yes you can damn you me
and that I'm going back surface god damn
it come on man all right I hope you try
this video if you did leave a like it
helps me out a lot and it makes you feel
better about what you're doing with your
life try it out who knows what will
happen maybe a unicorn will come and
have diarrhea on your face that would be
nice that'd be pretty cool I'd be quite
a story to tell your friends leave a
comment about the diarrhea unicorn and
how it looks like and I will see you
bros in the next video stay awesome bros
baja that's kind of a bold way to say
hello i am not wearing any pace i want
some [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]